I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there.
Today's episode is China. Season 7, episode 10. Episode 10. Yeah, we're more than a third of the way through season 7. Oh my gosh. This episode was written by Halstead Sullivan and Warren Lieberstein and it was directed by ACTION! Charles McDougall.
That's right. Here is your summary. As owner of the building, Dwight has made numerous cutbacks to electricity use, toilet paper that has everyone in The Office pretty grumpy. As office administrator, Pam goes toe-to-toe with Dwight, threatening to move Dunder Mifflin to a new office space. Meanwhile, Michael and Oscar find themselves competing for the title of smartest in The Office.
That was my favorite. Me too. Because it appears that Michael, not Oscar, actually knows more about China. Finally, Darryl regrets giving Andy his phone number because Andy will not stop texting him. He is blowing up that text thread. Yeah. Well, fast fact number one, this episode aired on December 2, 2010.
It was viewed by 7.31 million people and I remembered what I was doing when this episode came out. What? I was in Detroit and we were filming The Giant Mechanical Man. It's the movie that Lee wrote and directed. I was in it with Chris Messina and Tofer Grace. I got lots of photos from you on that set and the biggest parka I had ever seen. Yes.
I was like, you took the Detroit weather seriously. I mean, I think the first day we got there, it snowed and there's this scene we were shooting at the zoo because my character works at a zoo in the movie and I have a meet cute with Chris Messina. That's very cute. And it started like a flurry of snow falling as we met. It was so amazing and romantic and this was a really low budget movie. So there was no way we could have brought in snow machines to make it happen.
So you were so excited. You got a little bit of that weather magic. Yes. It was like we got this big budget looking moment and it was just the sky. Well, the photo you sent me, I'll never forget because your coat, I guess it's the first time I'd ever seen a coat like this, but now I'm like, I know they're common. It looked like you were wearing a sleeping bag. Yes.
It like went all the way to the ground. It was so cold. But lady, the reason why I bring this up is because we were trading emails during this time and I found some of these emails because, you know, in our book, Office BFFs, we talk about how we stay in touch now through voice messages, right? But this was before we were doing that. We were still typing it all out to each other long emails. So long.
So long. We would write each other like a journal entry, but better than my actual journal entries. Don't worry, Sam. It was better. I remember like sitting down and writing you like a small novel about my whole week. Well, you did that and I found it. Here's what you were doing the week of December 2nd, 2010.
You had bought your house in the spring, but you had not had a chance to nest yet. No, because I was working when I got my house. So you were using this hiatus to fully nest and you wrote me an email announcing a very exciting home purchase. Do you remember what it was? I do. It was a treadmill. I was so excited.
You guys, I looked for a long time and I bought one at Sears and it promptly became the place where I hung my sweaters and put boxes on it. You were so excited about it in your email. You really believed that this was going to kickstart a new habit in your life. It's such a joke. For any of you guys that follow me on Instagram, you know that I would just post photo after photo of what all I was using my treadmill for other than exercise. Yes.
It's a great place to dry clothes that you want to take out the dryer a little bit early. So that's real good. But you don't have it anymore. No, I finally just gave it to my neighbor because I was like, who am I kidding? How long did you have it? It was like, I mean, five, eight years? Yeah, it took me like a decade to give up on it to realize it was just storage. But then I reimagined the space.
Yes. I made myself a little nook. And it is so cute. And bringing it back to the book, you spent a lot of time working on Office BFFs from your new nook that went in the place of this treadmill. The treadmill slash storage area. But this email really brought back memories for me because I just remember this whole treadmill thing.
I was so, I was so determined. I don't know what the moral of that story is. I don't know. But maybe if you haven't used your treadmill in a long time, just get real with yourself. Yeah. And put in a cozy reading nook instead. It's okay. We give you permission today.
We're talking to you. You know who you are. You don't know who you are. All right. Moving on. Fast fact number two, we got a fan question from Hailey H. in Alberta, Canada. This was such a great episode, but also a very unusual premise. What was the inspiration for this episode?
Well, Hailey, we reached out to Warren and Halstead, who wrote this episode. And Halstead gave us some great intel on the inspiration for all of the various storylines in this episode. He said that the writers had been tossing around the idea of a China episode for a while because China had been rapidly rising as the next superpower, but that the real seed of this idea sprung from a discussion in the writer's room after they had watched the 2008 Olympic opening ceremony in Beijing. Because he remembered they were all just talking about just the sheer number of performers
and how they were all moving with precision and the drummers. And you know, Warren told us that in their first draft, they had Michael watching the 2008 Olympic opening ceremony on YouTube with Aaron. Oh, you know, I did read that in an earlier draft. Yeah. But it took him a little while to figure out how could this become an episode. He said eventually the writers came up with this really fun idea of Oscar being known as actually.
Yes, I love that. And that kind of grew into him being considered the smartest in the office and what would happen if Michael bested him. And then they joined the idea of focusing on China and then focusing on Michael becoming the smartest in the office to come up with this episode. But they also wanted to explore Dwight as the building owner. And since Pam was the new office administrator, they thought it would be really fun to have a showdown between the two of them.
And it really sets up some future episodes like even Classy Christmas, you know, she actually plans an amazing Christmas. They also like the idea of Pam having to deal with this rather than Michael, you know, like the whole banner on the side of the building that Pam has to do this. And then as far as the Andy and Daryl texting storyline, they said they really wanted to deepen the relationship between Andy and Daryl that kind of started when they made their band. They liked those two together.
They said texting was relatively new back then. Oh my God, we're so old. The iPhone had just come out in 2007 and we finally had this whole keyboard that we could text from. You didn't have to do like just one, one, one, two, two, all that if people even know what we're talking about. I know. Because we're so old.
I know. They said something that was very popular back at the time was this new idea of texting etiquette. So that's what they decided to throw into that relationship. This is so funny to me because, well, in the last few years, we got my mom, not a smartphone, but like an iPad. And so now she texts. She's never texted in her life.
She's in her 80s. And just like watching my mom's learning curve on texting is so adorable. And like, you know, like the moment your parent discovers an emoji is so cute. Well, I guess all the different generations have their own texting etiquette. Our generation writes full sentences with punctuation. I know. But apparently that's really annoying too. Is it the millennials hate that?
Or is it Gen Z? I don't know. We're looking at you guys in the face. Also, like somebody hates emojis. Yeah. What is it? I know for me, if you put a period at the end of the sentence, that means you're mad at the person.
See? That's what I mean. We put a period all the time, Cassie. I know a bunch of emojis is an old person thing, like a bunch of like the crying emoji for laughing. Oh, that's me. I do it all the time. What do you do if you're laughing so hard you're crying?
I don't know. I'm 38. Check in with someone who isn't me. Well, the other thing. Also, I guess to write out full words is considered ancient as well. There's all these abbreviations. That's also read as like a passive aggressive. Yeah.
Yeah. I write see you soon exclamation point and I write out every word, but I feel like someone else writes the letter C, the letter U and soon with no period or lower. Oh, yeah. Right. Oh, that's right. Don't capitalize anything. My gosh.
Isabel just taught me a new one. She had a cold bug and I was like, how are you feeling today? And she said, I'm going to get it wrong. She said, med. What's that mean? So med. You know, she's like, like you're, you're so, so you're like, oh yeah. Yes.
She's feeling mid. Mid. Oh, so I got it wrong. I got it wrong. I thought you were saying meth. I know. I thought you were saying mid, which is like, you know, in the middle, like so, so, oh, I know what's also not good, like a song that's mid would be bad.
Okay. Yeah. But let me ask you this question. Let's say Angela and I took a class on young people texting nothing would make me happier going, but if we did and then we started texting that way, would it be annoying? Like are you supposed to stay in your lane? Just stay in your generation. I don't know, but you know what I'm going to text is I feel mid and I'll let you know
what she writes back. So we're probably like, oh, you know what I mean? That's like when I was a kid, if another kid's parent dressed too cool, it became uncool. Yeah. Because they were like trying too hard. No. I know. I like, would we be trying too hard if we're trying to text for sure mid with no emojis?
I don't know. So one more quick little fact about this episode is Warren and Halstead said the original title was Michael fixes America. And then it became the lease because it was kind of focusing on the storyline between Pam and Dwight. But eventually they settled on China. That makes a lot of sense because I found an original draft called the lease. And at first I thought it was a missing episode.
I was like, ooh. Oh, that would have been a find. I know. But then as I started reading it, I was like, oh no, this is China. Halstead also pointed out that this episode is a theme of battles. It's Michael versus Oscar, Pam versus Dwight, and Daryl versus Andy. And in each one of the battles, the underdog wins. Oh yeah.
I liked that. All right. Moving on to fast fact number three, you know, toilet paper features very heavily in this episode. So much. There was a lot of toilet paper, a lot of un-flying and re-plying of toilet paper. Some Stanley sass when Pam suggests him to double up, he says, stay out of my business. I thought we could use a history of toilet paper.
Oh, could we? I can't wait. Wait, let me get comfortable. I'm getting my tea. Here's something that I found very interesting that is on theme with this episode, which is that, you know, paper, regular writing paper originated in China, and so did toilet paper. Huh, how about that?
Mass-produced commercial toilet paper began in the mid-1800s, but before that, in very ancient times, people used all kinds of other things. Here's the stuff they used to wipe their tush. Okay. Is this the uncottled anus as Dwight would have it? That's right. Okay. What's that?
Ah! Mm-hmm. Seashell. No. Animal fur. Ah. Leaves. No.
Sometimes people just rinsed themselves in water. That's like a bidet. Yeah, or snow. You know I love a bidet. That's a story for another time. It is. I would not want to put snow up there. It'd be very cold.
In Roman times, they used a sponge attached to a stick. Fancy. I saw a picture of it. It kind of looked like a luffa on the end of a branch. A stinky luffa. I mean, listen to what they would do. They would keep it in a bucket full of vinegar or salt water to sanitize it, and then you would sponge your butt with it after you pooped.
Okay. Some really rich people would use cloth, but because cloth was handmade at the time, that was considered like very decadent if you use cloth. But by the early 14th century, the Chinese were manufacturing toilet paper at around 10 million packages a year. But you know what? The modern toilet paper did not get to the west until 1857, and before that, you know what we were using over here?
Just don't say a shell. It was not a shell. Okay. We were using corn cobs. Corn cobs. Or old newspapers or magazines. Yeah. The first toilet paper roll was introduced in 1890, and then really the biggest milestone
in toilet paper happened in 1930, when Northern Tissue Company made the first splinter-free toilet paper. Splinters? All this time, people were wiping their butts with paper that had splinters? I had to read that several times. Good lord. Yeah, but thank you, Northern Tissue Company. Seriously.
Splinter-free since 1930. Good night. Here's something I learned. In 1973, America experienced its first toilet paper shortage, and it was all because of a joke that Johnny Carson made on The Tonight Show. What do you say? I have an audio clip. Ooh.
Of all the shortages we have, there's a gasoline shortage. You know what else is disappearing from the supermarket shelves? Toilet paper. Ha-ha-ha. You can laugh now. There is an acute shortage of toilet paper in the good old United States. You gotta quit writing on it. But I want to tell you, it is serious.
I just saw a commercial where... I know it's coming. Where Mrs. Olson comes in with a shopping bag, and the housewife says, forget the coffee, just give me the shopping bag. I want to tell you... Yes, yes. Oh! Okay, so here's the thing.
So based off that bit... Yeah, it seems sort of innocent, this joke, but I guess there was a gas shortage going on, and he had read an article that there was a commercial toilet paper shortage, but nothing to do with household toilet paper. But after people heard this joke, people made a run on the supermarket, and they bought up all the toilet paper and created a toilet paper shortage. And Johnny Carson had to release a statement. He said this.
Quote, I don't want to be remembered as the man who created a false toilet paper scare. I just picked up the item from the paper and enlarged it somewhat. There is no shortage. And quote. I like that that's how he doesn't want to be known. Yeah, please. All right, final thing before we go to break, Angela, about toilet paper. The hanging of your toilet paper on the roll is a huge source of debate.
People want to know, should the tail go over or under? Over. Over. Over it rolls more naturally. Over. What debate? Over. In a survey of Americans, 70 percent prefer over the top because those 70 percent of Americans
are right. Yes, you are correct, actually. There's a patent from 1891 for the Albany Perforated Wrapping Paper Company. They filed their patent, which shows it in the overhang fashion, and the patent was approved. This is the way it was designed to be used. Come on, you guys. 1891. 1891.
Who's the guy who applied for the patent? Sean Wheeler. Sean, thank you. Thank you for the over. For also proving us right. That's all I got for Fast Facts. Well, I loved all of that. Let's take a break because when we come back, there's a moment that Phyllis could not get
through. She laughed every time. They don't have a take of her not laughing, so what you see was just Phyllis trying not to completely lose it. Yeah, but you can see her kind of losing it, I know, but that was the best one they had. We are back and Dwight has decided that he is going to work on the dexterity of his feet. He is going to learn to use his feet to do things. This is what leads to him trying to drink a cup of coffee with his feet, and he spills
it on his crotch. You guys, Rain really did spill that on his crotch. He had to change pants. It was not hot, but Phyllis lost it every time. And you can see her covering her mouth with her hands, and we were all supposed to kind of be giggling, I guess, when he spills the coffee, but she's so completely out of character. I want you guys to look at 55 seconds. Did anyone else notice the coffee mug that Dwight is using?
Anyone else out there? I noticed it because it said Coney Island, which is far from Scrin. Okay, are you ready for a little mom detective journey? Please. Okay. So I went online to see if I could find the exact one that Dwight is using in this scene, and Jenna, I remembered that when we broke down the Saber episode, you had done some digging on hot dog eateries in Pennsylvania.
Yeah. Because Dwight has that great scene where he's holding the tray of hot dogs, and he doesn't know where to put them when he meets Gabe. All right, well, you found an article in Pennsylvania Eats about a local spot in Scranton called Coney Island lunch, and I was like, oh, that's got to be it. Right. They serve Texas wieners. This has got to be it.
But Dwight's mug said Coney Island, Texas lunch. So I started Googling, because we are lit as a Google, and I found two different restaurants. They had almost identical names, but two different storefronts, and I thought, well, maybe I've got this wrong. Right? Okay, there's two places in Scranton called Coney Island something. Yeah. So I was like, this has got to be wrong.
So I dug a little deeper, and then I came across this delightful blogger who writes about food as he travels. Okay. I only know him by his blogger handle, Hackknife, okay? So Hackknife, if you're out there, this delighted me. He was traveling to Ohio with his family over Thanksgiving a few years back, and he made a pit stop in Scranton for lunch. And here's what he had to say.
We walked up Lackawanna Avenue to find two very similar sounding restaurants located just a mere steps from each other, Coney Island, Texas lunch at 100 Cedar Ave, and Coney Island lunch at 515 Lackawanna Ave. Okay, wait. So the only thing that's different is one of them is called Texas lunch, and one of them is called lunch. That's right. Okay.
So here is what Hackknife learned after further investigation. Okay. The founder of Coney Island, Texas lunch was named Steve Caronpolis. Okay. He started the business, and then in 1972, when he passed away, he left it to his sons Ted and Jack. And everything was fine until 1987, when there was a dispute regarding the future direction of the business.
Ted wanted to keep renting space in the old building while Jack preferred ownership in a new location. The brothers went their separate ways. Jack opened up a rival, Coney Island lunch. No. No. And Ted cashed out to his partner in 2004, but they kept the original building, Coney Island, Texas lunch.
Here is original location, and now a set of owners runs that there. So you have Coney Island, Texas lunch, and you have Coney Island lunch, they're right around the corner from each other. And this is based on a feud between the brothers. Yes. But the one brother, Coney Island, Texas lunch, doesn't even own that anymore. He sold it. That's right.
But still operating out of the original location. That's right. I'm with you. Right. Okay. So your building, it can say, since 1923. Because it's been there. That's right.
Uh-huh. But Coney Island lunch managed to keep the original phone number. Now, who kept the menu? Do they serve the same stuff? Yes, because it's the same recipe for 93 years of this Texas wiener with the chili. So all of that to say, I then found Instagram accounts, and then I found both the restaurant's websites. Neither of them had a shop toggle.
So at the end of all this, I'm not getting a mug. You are not getting a mug. It's the end of this story. And they ended this story, which I think is how all mom detective journeys end, which is we may never know. We never get the original thing we were searching for. That's right. So well done.
And you know what? I read reviews of both restaurants, and people love both. Of course. It's the same food. Of course. It's the same recipe. I feel like if we go to Scranton, we're going to have to have a hot dog from both. Well, Angela, I loved that journey.
All right. Well, let's get into this episode. It begins with the shortest opening credits of all time. Did you notice? Yes. I noticed that Randy pointed that out to us too. I loved what he said in his email to us. He wrote, at 121, geez, could this top the leaderboard for shortest main title in the
show's history? Yeah. It was just the street, and then Michael moving his dundee. They clearly just had a lot they wanted to make sure stayed in. Yeah. This episode opens with Andy arriving to work. He's down in the lobby, and he finds Dwight's built a new coffee stand. I love that Hank had to work it.
I know. He's so clearly, like, annoyed by it. He said Dwight said that it was a waste of space, and now they're going to sell all kinds of things. They've got muffins, donuts, magazines, biscotti, a frosted bunt cake. There's a coffee station with sugar and sweeteners. It's called Caffeine Corner, and the muffins cost $8 we learn. You know, there's a real caffeine corner located in Berlin, New Jersey, and their muffins are
only $2.50. Better deal. Dwight is going to have a talking head where he says owning a building is a war between the landlord and the tenant. That's what he sees building ownership as, a war, I know. He says he's going to use some of the tactics like in war. He's going to surround the army, slowly starve them out. He installed a timer and motion sensor so the lights go off to save electricity, and it's
part of his green initiative, green, meaning money. I did look at the candy bag alts for this talking head because I knew they had a bunch of different alts, and they did. There were a few that were hilarious. Here was one of my favorites that I'll share. Dwight would say, to save on electricity, I've installed a timer and a motion sensor on the lights. I've also unplugged Kevin's, Creed's, and Meredith's computers they have yet to notice.
Nice. Michael is going to enter for the day, and he's hot to trot. Yeah, he's picking up stuff on Aaron's desk. Everything's made in China. Aaron's like, what's up? Well, it turns out that when he went to the dentist, the magazine he wanted to read was not available. A kid was reading it.
Right. So he had to read that one. He had to read Newsweek. Yeah. And it was all about China. He still has the magazine. He's taken it from the dentist's office. Yeah.
He read it once, and he read it again. Randy Cordray told us that that was not a real Newsweek magazine, but we did get the rights from Newsweek Magazine. James Carey was able to get those for us. Wow. So we could put their logo on there, but we had to make our own magazine. So the cover was designed by Henry Sain, and Phil Shea had it printed at Earl Hay Press. Fakie magazine.
This is going to lead us to the first Daryl and Andy text exchange runner. I loved this so much. I loved when Daryl said, you need to change your standard for what's a worthy text. Ask yourself, is this something Daryl needs to know? The answer almost always no. This scene leads to a Daryl talking head. He says, there was a time when the only people who texted you were the people you wanted to text you, like girls.
Yeah. Right? So he had shared something fun with us about this talking head. He said that Craig came up with a BTB joke on the spot. The bring that booty? Uh-huh. Oh, that's fun. That was a Craig improv.
Is that a real thing? Is that a BTB? Anyone? Is that a real? Young people? BTB. Bring that booty? Or did Craig just make that up?
A texting booty call? You've never heard this? I have not. No, I have not. Okay. All right. I would assume it would be... It was made up.
It would be bringing it already. Like if I was going there. You've never sounded older. You've never sounded older. I don't need to text BTB. She's already bringing it. That's implied. The booty's coming.
I don't... That was the most old man you've ever seen. Get off my porch. Oh, my gosh. The next thing that happens is that Stanley is really upset that Dwight has been putting single-ply toilet paper in the bathroom. I have a catch. What's your catch?
Jim has a rubber band ball. Yes, he does. And it's going to keep coming back. That's right. I went to the shooting draft. No mention of rubber band ball. So then I went to our table read draft. And this is all it said.
And it comes back a few times. Interior office, Jim, Pam, and Dwight are at their desk. Jim is making a rubber band ball, Stanley approaches. That's it. That's all I could find. Hmm. That's all it said. Yeah, that's all it said.
That's so crazy. I know. I know that from Vashnave S. in India, I'm sure I wasn't the only one to notice that Stanley pulls a major John Krasinski. In this episode at three minutes and 29 seconds, we get a big D. White from Stanley. Yeah. It's true. I also had my own catch for this scene at four minutes and 47 seconds.
Kate is playing solitaire on her computer and Oscar is reading a book or a script in the background. You know what? And Angela, you, it's very interesting, are just sitting there. You're just sitting there and you kind of put your hands together. You're just sitting.
You know why? Why? I was freezing. Oh yes, that makes sense. I'm like, what is she doing with her hand? I was freezing. Oscar, by the way, would often bring a book to read. Okay.
And he would sit there and read and I'd be like, you're on camera. And he's like, can Oscar be reading? Like he's reading. I mean, it makes sense. Well, Pam was gonna step in as office administrator and say, Dwight, we need to have better toilet paper. You need to take care of all this.
Yeah, but he says, you know, when he's at Dunder Mifflin, he's Dwight Shrut, a salesperson. If she wants to talk to Dwight Shrut building owner, she should call Nate and make an appointment. Pam calls Nate. Okay, Jenna, you and Mark had so many more scenes that did not make it in.
I remember. They're in deleted scenes. They're in the shooting draft. They are so funny. He was so funny. He's hilarious. Nate ultimately tells Pam that his boss is busy. Dwight is busy.
Well, first of all, Pam can hear all of this. Dwight's like, just make something up. And the thing that go to that Nate says is he's being questioned about a string of dog nappings. Yeah. That Dwight is part of a string of dog nappings. Yes. And Pam's like, you know what, Dwight?
You're really screwing over your friends here, your coworkers. Like this is affecting all of us and you need to do something about it. In deleted scenes, this moment was bigger. And when Dwight has the line about Kevin smiling. Yes. John was in the background,
instant messaging someone on his screen. What? Yes. No way. It was so clear. Remember the AIM little box we would get? Yes. Because we're dinosaurs?
Mm-hmm. He was instant messaging someone. I tried to zoom in to see who it was, but it was too blurry. Our next scene is gonna be in Michael's office where he and Aaron are researching China on Wikipedia. And I'll have you know, that was the actual China Wikipedia page.
We just cleared it to use it. Well, Aaron's gonna find out that according to the internet, the tallest band in the world is Chinese. And Michael says so much for keeping our secrets up high. I mean, that's the most ridiculous thing to say. He decides though, he's gonna put the best minds in America on this.
And that is the Dunder Biflin bullpen. Yeah. He charges into the bullpen. It's clearly DEF CON 5 again. And he needs our biggest ideas because we need to get ahead. Kevin's ready to go. Kevin's raising his hand.
Oh yeah. An acid once a week. Yeah. And then Michael's like, okay, that's what we have to beat. An acid once a week. Once a week, an acid. I know.
It's so good. There was a part of the scene that I labeled WTF for the kids out there. They know what that means. Oh yeah, Aaron's whole thing. What the heck? It was so great. She says, hey, you guys,
I have an idea. How about we hire someone new, take out a million dollar life insurance policy on them and then kill them. And then she has a talking head where she says, I think that's what they're doing to me. I can't prove it, but I just wanted to see their faces when I said it.
What? She learned nothing though. Immediately after Aaron shares this, Michael says, I don't know what the f*** that was. We got a fan question from KCA and Edmonton, Alberta, Canada, who said, I need to know if that line was scripted or improv.
That was totally improvised. Oh, I remember when he did it and we all started laughing. Yeah. And the crazy thing is in that moment, Michael was all of us. Michael was the audience. Yes. Well, Randy said that leaving that improvisation in
was, you know, a big deal for standards and practices. Here we go. After watching a rough cut of this episode, we got this note, quote, scene 13, Michael's f*** remark must be bleeped completely. We're hearing the leading F sound and blur his lip flap. No lip flap on my watch. And then later,
after they watched the final locked cut, they got this note, quote, scene 12, blur the lip flap when Michael says f***. Once again. Mm-hmm. Jenna and I got the funniest tweet. His name is Josh Roller. Here's what he had to say.
Josh, this cracked us up. I was today years old when it struck me that standards and practices is to the editors of the office, what Toby Flindersen is to Michael Scott. Thanks, Josh. I love that. So now is when Michael is gonna start giving us a lot of statistics about China,
which Oscar is going to refute. Yeah, actually he is. And guess what? Michael got his info right. Yes. So they were going back and forth about China's population, whether they were agrarian, urbanizing quickly.
And Michael says that China had 56 cities with a population of over one million and the US has nine and he was right. Ryan fact checked it. He was correct. Immediately Meredith is like, suck it, Oscar. Everyone is so excited that Michael bested Oscar. Well, you know who else is right in the scene?
然后迈克尔说中国有56个城市人口超过百万，美国只有9个，他是对的。瑞恩核实过了。他是对的。梅雷迪思立刻就说，去你的，奥斯卡。大家都为迈克尔胜过奥斯卡而兴奋不已。嗯，你知道这场景里还有谁是对的吗？
Who? Dwight. We had a fan catch from Carly P and Cesar Illinois, who said at six minutes and 57 seconds, Dwight says that by 2020, China would be the largest economy. I looked it up and he was right. China was the largest economy in 2020
谁？德怀特。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州卡莉·P和凯撒的粉丝留言，他们在6分57秒时说，德怀特说过到2020年，中国将成为最大的经济体。我查了一下，他是对的。中国在2020年成为最大经济体，
with 24.16 trillion, I guess, dollars. And they were also the world's largest manufacturer and exporter. We are finding out that Dwight is like, oddly correct about so many random things. But I feel like we rarely believe him. I know. And then we dig a little and we're like,
我猜产值达到了24.16万亿美元。而且他们还是世界最大的制造商和出口商。我们发现德怀特对于这么多随机的事情竟然都有着诡异的准确预测。但我觉得我们很少相信他。我知道。然后我们稍微深挖一下就会发现，
oh, well, yeah, I guess that's true. We do like men who smell like our fathers. I guess so. Michael is so delighted he has a talking head and he's like, so I happen to know more than the smartest guy in the office. So what? I don't care.
哦，好吧，是的，我想那是真的。我们确实喜欢闻起来像我们父亲的男人。我想是的。迈克尔高兴极了，他有一个单独访谈，他说，所以我碰巧知道得比办公室里最聪明的人还多。那又怎样？我不在乎。
Like he's so happy. But when we go back out in the bullpen, all of a sudden the room gets dark, but the lights did not go out. It's something else. It's a disgusting, enormous banner. It's bright yellow with big cockroaches on it with a slogan that says, A and J exterminators,
就像他高兴得不得了。但当我们回到办公区时，突然房间变暗了，但灯并没有灭。是别的东西。是一个恶心、巨大的横幅。它是亮黄色的，上面有大大的蟑螂，标语写着：“A&J害虫防治公司，
we're roach killers. That's what we do. Yeah, Dwight has sold the space of the outside of the building for advertising. And you know, this banner was a whole thing. I bet it was pricey. It was the size of the building. I know.
我们是灭蟑专家。这就是我们的业务。”是的，德怀特把大楼外面的空间租出去做广告了。你知道，这个横幅可是个大工程。我敢说它价格不菲。它有整栋楼那么大。我知道。
I remember when they unfurled it and we were standing there and I was like, oh, holy crap, how do you even make something this large? I know. It was the size of a billboard, but it was all one piece, right? With billboards, don't they put it up in pieces? I've seen them do it.
我还记得当他们把它展开时，我们站在那里，我当时想，哦，天哪，你怎么能做出这么大的东西？我知道。它有一个广告牌那么大，但它是一整块的，对吧？广告牌不都是一块一块拼上去的吗？我看过他们这样做。
I don't know. I don't know billboard artistry. But this is- You've never seen a billboard going up in progress? It's really interesting. I mean, you could just grab a coffee and watch it happen. It's fascinating. I guess maybe if I dig back in my brain,
我不知道。我可不懂广告牌的艺术。但这-你从来没见过广告牌在搭建中的过程吗？真的很有意思。我的意思是，你可以顺便买杯咖啡看着它完工。太迷人了。我想也许如果我在脑海里搜寻一下，
I've been driving and someone's been rolling a thing up there. Yeah. You know, they don't put it all up in one piece. Well, I'm sorry, Jenna. I've never pulled over and watched the whole thing. Like you have with a cup of coffee, not the weird lady in the car. I love-
我以前开车时见过有人在上面卷什么东西。是的。你知道，他们不是一下子把它整块装上去的。好吧，对不起，珍娜。我从来没有把车停在路边看完整个过程。不像你还拿着杯咖啡，才不像车里的那个怪女士。我喜欢-
Ah! Oh my God, what? What happened? What just happened? God. What just happened? Angela just shoved away from the table and threw her earphones off.
啊！哦天哪，什么？怎么了？刚刚发生了什么？天哪。刚刚发生了什么？安吉拉刚才猛地从桌子旁推开，把耳机甩掉了。
Did a bug get you? It's hard to explain over an audio podcast, how hard Angela, what just happened? She flew about, I'd say, a foot and a half back. It was like, did you get shocked? You look like in the movies, where you get shocked by an electrical wire and the whole body flies backwards.
有虫子咬你吗？在音频播客里很难解释安吉拉当时的反应有多大，刚刚到底怎么了？她往后飞了大概，我可以说有一英尺半。那感觉就像，你被电击了吗？你看起来就像电影里那样，被电线电到整个人往后飞。
My brain went to, do you remember when the exorcist, where she shoves her back with her mental powers? I crossed my leg and my thigh hit the volume button and all of a sudden, you went to tin in my ear. And it was so painful. And it was right as you were saying, I know! Oh no. You thought she just got to, you've never seen a billboard?
我的脑子马上想到了，还记得《驱魔人》里吗，她用精神力量把自己的后背猛推出去？我翘起二郎腿，大腿撞到了音量键，突然间，你的声音直接刺进我耳朵里。太痛苦了。而且正好是在你说“我知道！”的时候。哦不。你以为她只是去过，你从来没见过广告牌？
I don't know what happened. Are you okay? I'm okay. I have to pee now. I don't know, it triggered everything. Oh dear. Well, maybe we should take a break then. I'm so sorry.
我不知道发生了什么。你还好吗？我没事。我现在得去上厕所了。我不知道，这触发了所有开关。哦天哪。好吧，那我们也许该休息一下了。真的很抱歉。
Let's do that. Let's take a break and then I'll give you all of the details on this giant banner because it's pretty fascinating. And now I feel like I need to go to YouTube and learn how you make a billboard because maybe it's how I need to start my day with a cup of tea.
那就这样吧。我们休息一下，然后我会把这个巨型横幅的所有细节都告诉你们，因为这真的挺迷人的。现在我觉得我需要去YouTube上学学怎么制作广告牌了，因为这也许正是我需要用一杯茶开启一天的方式。
I love watching slices of life. I do too. We're gonna go to break. Sam found you a video called installing a billboard. Let's watch it. We'll be right back. ["The Banner"] All right, so we are back.
我喜欢看生活切片。我也是。我们要去休息一下。山姆给你找了一个叫“安装广告牌”的视频。我们看一下。马上回来。 [《横幅》] 好吧，我们回来了。
And let me tell you about this banner. So the first thing we had to do was we had to have something come down behind our windows inside the bullpen, you know, inside the office. Right, to cast that big shadow. Yes. And I guess it was a big deal
让我来告诉你们关于这个横幅的事。所以我们要做的第一件事，就是必须在办公区里面的窗户后面弄个东西掉下来，你知道的，就是在办公室里面。对，为了投下那个巨大的阴影。是的。我猜这可是个大事，
because those windows are fake and behind them is, you know, the fakey backdrop. Right. At the street. But they had to completely re-rig that whole area because we had all kinds of stuff there, like electrical, lights, all kind of stuff.
因为那些窗户是假的，后面你知道的，是假的背景板。就在街景那里。但他们必须完全重新布置那个区域，因为我们那里有各种各样的东西，比如电路、灯光，各种乱七八糟的东西。
And they had to design something that looked like it would be the backside of the thing we're gonna see outside. They had to make two banners? They did. They had to make a partial one that would come down over those windows. And then they had to make the real giant one
而且他们必须设计一个看起来像是我们在外面看到的那个东西的背面。他们必须制作两个横幅吗？是的。他们必须制作一个部分遮挡的横幅，可以垂下来盖住那些窗户。然后他们必须制作真正巨大的那个，
that was outside. And it cost us $3,900 for both of those banners. They were designed by Michael Gallenberg and Henry Sain. And they were built at a, I guess, no longer in business banner supply store in Van Nuys. So our crew, led by Tim James, rigged the banner on top of the stage.
也就是挂在外面的那个。这两个横幅一共花掉了我们3,900美元。它们是由迈克尔·盖伦伯格和亨利·塞恩设计的。它们是在范奈斯一家我猜现在已经倒闭的横幅供应商那里制作的。所以我们的剧组在蒂姆·詹姆斯的带领下，把横幅固定在舞台顶部。
Okay. And Mark was really up on the roof. Oh yeah, when we did the exterior. Yes. But Mark didn't drop it. They had guys there. Yes, we had crew up there who really let it down. And, you know, we were doing all this.
好的。马克真的是上了屋顶。哦对，我们拍外景的时候。是的。但马克可没有把它放下来。他们有专业人员在那儿。是的，我们有剧组人员在上面真正把它放了下来。而且，你知道，我们当时在做这一切。
We had to have a safety officer. Safety meeting. Safety meeting, banner coming down. Make sure you stay away from the building in case it falls off completely. You know, I just recently worked with Kelly Cantley. Yes. And she made a video for you guys, our Office Ladies
我们必须有一个安全员。安全会议。安全会议，横幅要放下来了。确保你们远离大楼，以防它完全掉下来。你知道，我最近和凯利·坎特利合作过。是的。她为你们制作了一个视频，我们的“办公室女士”
listeners and Jenna. Ah! Ready? Yes. Now you guys know Kelly is who Jenna and I would run up to and say, Kelly, we have to go pee. Can we go before this scene? Can we go after?
听众们和珍娜。啊！准备好了吗？是的。现在你们知道凯利就是我和珍娜会跑过去对她说：“凯利，我们要去上厕所。我们能在这一场之前去吗？我们能在之后去吗？”的人。
And sometimes she would say this to us and it became one of our favorite things. This is one of our catchphrases. We still say it. Ready? Kelly Cantley, first AD. This is for you, Jenna. That's Brian in the background.
有时她会这样对我们说，这成了我们最喜欢的事情之一。这是我们的口头禅之一。我们现在还在说。准备好了吗？凯利·坎特利，第一副导演。这是送给你的，珍娜。背景里那是布莱恩。
This is for you. Ready? Kelly, I have to go pee. Quick, like a bunny. Quick, like a bunny. Quick, like a bunny. She even has a little bunny on her laptop. Oh, really?
这是送给你的。准备好了吗？凯利，我得去上厕所。快如脱兔。快如脱兔。快如脱兔。她的笔记本电脑上甚至还有一只小兔子。哦，真的吗？
Yeah. Everybody is very upset by this. Maybe Gabe the most, because apparently we learn he has a fear of cockroaches. Yeah. He has to run inside. He can't look at them. Yeah.
对。每个人都对这个感到非常不安。也许加布受到的打击最大，因为显然我们得知他患有恐蟑症。对。他必须跑进去。他根本不敢看。对。
Angela says, Michael, take care of this. And he turns to Pam and says, take care of it. Office administrator, handle it. Yeah. Pam tells Dwight to take it down, but he just laughs. She says, take it down or else. Or else what Dwight says? We'll move out.
安吉拉说：“迈克尔，处理一下这个。”然后他转向帕姆说：“处理一下。办公室行政，搞定它。”是的。帕姆让德怀特把它拿下来，但他只是笑。她说：“把它拿下来，否则……”“否则怎么样？”德怀特说，“我们就搬走。”
Dun, dun, dun. Well, then we go to the kitchen, Angela. I know. And this was the writers having fun. I even remember the table read, everyone cracked up because I'm so short. This is a short person joke. The lights go out in the kitchen
咚，咚，咚。好吧，然后我们去了厨房，安吉拉。我知道。这是编剧们在自娱自乐。我甚至还记得剧本围读的时候，大家都笑疯了，因为我太矮了。这是一个关于矮个子的笑话。厨房里的灯熄灭了，
and you can't get them to come back on again because you're too short for the motion sensor. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Interior kitchen. Angela is in the kitchen and the lights go off. She waves and jumps, but nothing happens. Kevin walks through and the lights go back on. Has this ever happened to you in real life?
而你没办法让它们重新亮起来，因为你太矮了，触发不了动作感应器。拍摄初稿里是这样写的。内景：厨房。安吉拉在厨房里，灯熄灭了。她挥手又跳跃，但什么都没发生。凯文走过，灯又亮了。这在现实生活中发生过在你身上吗？
Have you ever been too tiny to set off a motion sensor? Oh yeah, all the time. We have a motion sensor on the side of our house. You know by the back door where the trash bins are? Josh walks out and it turns on. I walk out and nothing happens. I have to wave my hand at it. Yeah.
你有没有因为太矮而无法触发动作感应器？哦，经常。我们房子侧面就有一个动作感应器。你知道垃圾桶旁边的后门那里吗？乔希走出去，它就亮了。我走出去，什么都没发生。我必须对它挥手。对。
Yeah, no, this is my life. Well, Pam is gonna return and she says, does anyone wanna know where I've been for the last two hours? Jim says, oh God, I've been playing zombie soccer for two hours. I had to look it up. Is it real?
没错，这就是我的生活。好吧，帕姆要回来了，她说：“有人想知道我过去两个小时去哪儿了吗？”吉姆说：“哦天哪，我玩了两个小时的僵尸足球。”我特意去查了一下。那是真的吗？
It is real. It's a real game? It's a real game. It turns out it came out in 2010, which would have been when this episode was filmed. Yeah. It's called, if this is the one they were referring to, the one I found is called Pro Zombie Soccer.
那是真的。真的是个游戏？是个游戏。原来它是2010年发售的，正好是这一集拍摄的时候。是的。它叫做——如果这就是他们指的那个的话，我找到的那个叫做《职业僵尸足球》（Pro Zombie Soccer）。
It's a game that features a protagonist named Jax, who's a wannabe soccer star, who is infected as a result of a zombie bite from another soccer player. Oh. Who was a zombie. Okay. The players must quickly defeat hordes of zombies
这个游戏的主角是一个叫贾克斯的人，他是一个梦想成为足球明星的人，结果被另一个足球运动员僵尸咬伤而感染了。哦。那个球员是个僵尸。好吧。玩家必须迅速击败成群的僵尸，
before Jax succumbs to the effects of the zombie infection. So you're playing soccer and fighting zombies at the same time? I guess so. It's both? It's both, and Jim played it for two hours. It's very interesting. I have another thing about this scene.
在贾克斯被僵尸病毒感染发作之前。所以你一边踢足球一边打僵尸？我猜是的。两者皆有？两者兼有，而且吉姆玩了两个小时。非常有趣。关于这个场景我还有一件事。
When Pam shows the photos of this new workspace to Dwight, there was a really funny gym runner here, and it got deleted, but we learned a little something that annoys Jim about Pam. Oh. Oh, wow. These are nice.
当帕姆向德怀特展示这个新办公空间的合影时，这里有一个非常搞笑的吉姆加戏，但被删掉了，不过我们从中了解到了吉姆对帕姆感到厌烦的一点小事。哦。哦，哇。这些挺好看的。
Did you take these? Yep. Let me see. What camera? Look at the huge offices, Jim. Yeah, no. Check out that conference room. Totally.
这是你拍的？对。我看看。什么相机？看这些大办公室，吉姆。对，没错。看看那个会议室。完全是。
If you just ask, I totally won't let you borrow it. It's just that. Hey, Jim, can I use your camera? That's all. What is that, like five words? It's not a big deal. Can I use your camera please? Not that extra please in there.
如果你只是问一下，我绝对不会不借给你。就是那种。嘿，吉姆，我能用一下你的相机吗？就这。那是什么，大概五个字？这又没什么大不了的。请问我能用一下你的相机吗？里面连那个多余的“请”字都没有。
Still not hard. She just always changes the settings, and. Jim, isn't that so funny? So when you go re-watch the scene, I want you to look for Jim's reactions to the photos that Pam's showing. It's not about the office space. It's about the fact this whole time
依然不难。她只是总是更改设置，而且。吉姆，这难道不好笑吗？所以当你回去重看这个场景时，我希望你们注意吉姆对帕姆展示的照片的反应。重点不是办公空间。重点在于，一直以来
Jim thinks that Pam took his camera and didn't ask. And I was so curious when I watched the scene, I thought, Jim is acting kind of weird. Yeah, and that's why. It's why. It's because he's annoyed, because Pam takes his camera and changes all the settings. This is a clear case of Jim thinking of it as his camera
吉姆都认为帕姆拿了他的相机却没有问过他。我当时看这一场时觉得很好奇，我想，吉姆的举动有点怪。是的，这就是原因。这就是原因。因为他很恼火，因为帕姆拿了他的相机，还把所有设置都改了。这明显是一个典型的例子：吉姆觉得那是他的相机，
and Pam thinking of it as their camera. Right? Yeah. Well, Pam is really going to sell this new workspace to the whole office. She's passing around the photos to everyone. It kind of sounds too good to be true, because it seems to have something for everyone.
而帕姆觉得那是他们的相机。对吧？是的。好吧，帕姆真的要把这个新办公空间推销给整个办公室了。她把照片传给每个人看。听起来似乎好得有点不真实，因为它似乎能满足每个人的需求。
It's next to an outback, so it always smells like steak. It's next to a nail place that makes Kelly very happy. Later, one of my favorite things in the stairwell is when Jim says, wait, so it's not near a bike path? I know. Like she's clearly just found something about it for everyone. Warren shared with us that there was a different version
它挨着一家澳拜客牛排馆，所以总是飘着牛排的香味。它挨着一家美甲店，这让凯利非常高兴。后来，楼梯间里我最喜欢的桥段之一就是吉姆说：“等等，所以它不在自行车道旁边？”我知道。就像她明显只是为每个人都找到了一个心仪的亮点。沃伦跟我们分享说，其实还有一个不同版本的场景，
where Pam is going around talking to everyone about this great new office, and Pam approaches Toby, and this is how the scene would have played out. Toby tells Pam that he's resistant to move, because moving is one of the most five-stressful things in life, along with work, loneliness, debt, and divorce, which he has experienced way too often in a myriad of ways.
讲的是帕姆到处跟每个人谈论这个棒极了的新办公室，帕姆走近托比，这个场景原本是这样发展的：托比告诉帕姆他抗拒搬迁，因为搬家是人生中最有压力的五件事之一，与工作、孤独、债务和离婚并列，而他在各种方面已经经历过太多次离婚了。
But if this new office had a window, then maybe he could get the cactus that he always wanted. And Warren said, oh, Toby, it was really difficult to turn in a script without at least one sad Toby remark. Randy told us that those photos weren't taken by Michael Gallenberg, and they were actually scouting photos. When we were shooting the sting, we were looking at locations
但如果这个新办公室有一扇窗户，那么也许他就能得到他一直想要的仙人掌了。沃伦说：“哦，托比，要交出一份至少没有一句托比式悲伤台词的剧本，可真是太难了。”兰迪告诉我们，那些照片根本不是迈克尔·盖伦伯格拍的，实际上是勘景照片。我们在拍刺探戏的时候，在寻找外景地，
that maybe we could go on location for those scenes where Dwight and Michael and Jim run into Danny Cordray. And I guess this was one of the spots that they scouted, so we just had these old photos. And that's what Pam is showing everybody. Well, I think we should title this next scene actually in the process of shooting the scene. Actually in the break room.
看看我们是否可以实景拍摄德怀特、迈克尔和吉姆偶遇丹尼·科德雷的那些场景。我想这就是他们勘察过的其中一个地点，所以我们手头刚好有这些旧照片。这就是帕姆拿给大家看的东西。嗯，我觉得我们应该给接下来这个场景起个名，实际上就是在拍这个场景时。实际上是在茶水间。
Oh, I had a different title. What was it? I called it Brains in the Break Room. Oh, that's probably better. So everyone's in the break room, and Oscar's going to walk in. And Kelly's really like teasing him. And Kelly and Ryan are like, oh, actually Oscar, actually. And that's when we have this Jim talking head, where
哦，我起的是另一个名字。叫什么？我把它叫作“茶水间里的智者”。哦，那个可能更好。所以大家都在茶水间里，奥斯卡要走进来。凯利真的在取笑他。凯利和瑞恩就像是，“哦，其实嘛，奥斯卡，其实嘛。”然后我们就有了一个吉姆的单独访谈，他在访谈里说
he says Oscar is known as quote, actually, because of the way he inserts himself into every conversation to add facts or correct grammar. And then there's a montage of Oscar walking by going, actually, actually. But then Oscar's going to ask Michael to go to coffee. He's like, you know what, Michael? I'd like to hear some more of those China facts.
奥斯卡被称为“其实先生”（Actually），因为他总是喜欢插话到任何对话中去补充事实或纠正语法。接着是一段蒙太奇，奥斯卡走过来说着：“其实……其实……”但接着奥斯卡要请迈克尔去喝咖啡。他说：“你知道吗，迈克尔？我想听听你多讲点那些关于中国的冷知识。”
This is a trap. Yeah, Andy, Jim, everyone, they're freaking out. They're like, whoa, whoa, whoa. Michael, this is a trap. Oscar's going to set you up. Yes. Well, Michael has already accepted the invitation. So just to be safe, he's going to try to learn everything
这是一个陷阱。是的，安迪、吉姆，所有人都吓坏了。他们说：“哇，哇，哇。迈克尔，这是个陷阱。奥斯卡要给你下套。”是的。好吧，迈克尔已经接受了邀请。所以为了安全起见，他要试着去了解所有
he can about China. And probably geography and math and literature. But you know what? He's good on politics. He's got that down. Yeah, apparently. And in the meantime, Andy is still trying to text Darrell something good.
关于中国的事情。可能还有地理、数学和文学。但你知道吗？他在政治方面很在行。他已经掌握了。是的，显然如此。与此同时，安迪还在试图给达瑞尔发短信说点好听的。
Darrell's at the photocopier. And he gets a text that just says Megan Fox. Darrell's going to say, listen, you are one bad text away from getting blocked. Ah, but one good text away from a high five, Andy says. I really wish we could say this, though. I wish that you could just have a rule, that you have a limit of bad text,
达瑞尔正在复印机旁。他收到了一条短信，上面只写着“梅根·福克斯”。达瑞尔要说了：“听着，你再发一条烂短信就要被拉黑了。”啊，但离击掌庆祝只差一条好短信了，安迪说。我真的很希望我们能这么说，真的。我希望你们能立个规矩，限制烂短信的数量，
and then you could tell someone, listen, you're one text away from being blocked. And it's OK. It's an accepted rule. I often feel overwhelmed by text threads, the text threads. Yeah. It's a lot. It's a lot.
然后你就可以对某人说：“听着，你再发一条短信就要被拉黑了。”这没关系。这是一个被接受的规则。我经常被短信群聊搞得焦头烂额，各种短信群聊。是的。信息量太大了。信息量太大了。
And sometimes you have to scroll way back. Someone will make a reference way later, and then you're like, what are they talking about? Yeah. I know. At 11 minutes and eight seconds, I have a question about this scene, which is, why is Darrell making a photocopy
有时你不得不拼命往回翻。有人会在很久之后引用一个梗，然后你会想：他们在说什么呢？我知道。在11分08秒时，我对这个场景有一个疑问，那就是，为什么达瑞尔在复印时不把盖子放下？这让我很困扰。我不知道。我的意思是，这样真的行吗？不把盖子放下也能复印吗？
without putting the top down? It bothered me. I don't know. I mean, does that even work? Can you even make a photocopy if you don't put the top down? I tried to Google it. I couldn't find out. I think you can.
我试图用谷歌搜索。我没找到答案。我觉得可以。
Really? Yeah. All right. Well, I just, I mean, the light flashing up as he made it. It was, it's a pet peeve. It was disturbing for you. Just put the lid down, everybody. If I'm with you, will you put the lid down for me, I guess.
真的吗？对。好吧。总之，我就是——我的意思是，他复印时闪烁的亮光。这是一个强迫症痛点。这让你觉得很不舒服。大家把盖子放下好吗。如果我和你在一起，你会帮我把盖子放下吗，我猜。
That's what I'm saying. Yes, I'll put the lid down. Thank you. In the kitchen, we're going to have some pirate talk. Mm-hmm. Dwight walks by, says, Parley, my office, five minutes. Yep. Pam's like Parley.
这就是我想说的。是的，我会把盖子放下的。谢谢。在厨房里，我们要来点海盗对话。嗯哼。德怀特走过来说：“帕利（Parley，谈判），来我办公室，五分钟。”是的。帕姆说：“帕利？”
Creed's like pirate code. He wants to meet. Yeah. By the way, Creed cannot speak pirate, but he can understand it. Yeah. Here's what Dwight is going to agree to. He's going to agree to stop watering down the soap.
克里德说：“海盗暗号。他想开会。”是的。顺便说一句，克里德不会说海盗话，但他能听懂。是的。这是德怀特将要同意的条件。他同意不再往肥皂里兑水稀释。
If Pam agrees not to move. Then they have this back and forth. That is so good. Antonia, I just wanted to read Pam's final put down. OK, please. Dwight has made some horrible predictions about what her future role looked like with Jim, with CeCe. Pam says, that's a sad story.
如果帕姆同意不搬走的话。然后他们开始了这种来回交锋。太精彩了。安东尼娅，我只想读一下帕姆最后的绝杀。好的，请吧。德怀特对她未来与吉姆、与西西的角色关系做出了可怕的预测。帕姆说：“那是个悲伤的故事。
I have another one. We move. The other tenants follow. The bank takes the building, takes your farm, takes your car, and beats the crap out of you. Pennyless, you die. And my daughter, CeCe, dances on your grave, fully clothed. And then the lights go off, and they both
我还有一个。我们搬走，其他租客也跟着走。银行收了这栋楼，收了你的农场，收了你的车，把你打得屁滚尿流。你一贫如洗，客死他乡。而我的女儿西西，在你坟头蹦迪，穿得整整齐齐。”然后灯熄灭了，他们两个
have to wave their arms to get them back on. It was really hard for me to do that without laughing. I think you can even see I'm smiling a little bit at the end of the scene. I just like the idea that it's the bank that beats up Dwight. Well, in the background of the scene, the whole time this is going on, Nate is at a very elaborate machine where he is turning one
不得不挥舞双手让灯重新亮起来。我当时忍住不笑拍完这一场真的很难。我想你甚至能看出我在场景结束时有点在笑。我只是喜欢“银行把德怀特暴打一顿”这个设定。好吧，在这个场景的背景中，这一切发生的同时，内特正站在一台非常复杂的机器前，把一卷手纸
roll of toilet paper into two rolls because he's separating the plies. This machine looks like something you would see on a school field trip if you went to like Ye Olde Farming Mine. Yes. Where you got to like churn butter and pick some apples, and there'd be this machine in the corner.
撕成两卷，因为他在分层。这台机器看起来就像你在学校春游时去那种“老式农矿旧址”会看到的设备。是的。在那里你可以去打黄油、摘苹果，角落里就会有这样一台机器。
Well, Jenna, we got a fan question from Akankasha in India. How on earth did Phil Shea make the toilet paper spool thing? Did it actually work? Did he give the assignment to an outside person or organization? How much did it cost to make? I have all the same questions. Well, thanks to Randy Cordray, we have the answer. This device cost us $3,000 in materials and overtime labor.
好吧，珍娜，我们收到了来自印度阿坎卡莎的粉丝提问：菲尔·谢伊到底是怎么做出那个手纸卷轴装置的？它真的管用吗？他是把这个任务交给了外部人员还是机构？制作成本是多少？我有完全一样的问题。好吧，多亏了兰迪·科德雷，我们有了答案。这个装置的花费是3,000美元的材料费和加班人工费。
Basically, this was a homemade machine. Phil Shea went out and found an old-timey hand crank off of some sort of antique device and then built a toilet paper splitting loom. You are kidding. This was. So they had this built. Someone built this.
基本上，这是一台自制机器。菲尔·谢伊出去找了一个老式的古董手摇柄，然后组建了一台手纸分层织布机。你在开玩笑吧。这是。所以他们把这个做出来了。有人做出来了。
It was their job. Yes. Phil had to go to the engineers at the hand prop room. Remember that place? Yeah. And they designed it and made it. Randy said, remember Dwight's nutcracker Christmas gift from Secret Santa?
这就是他们的工作。是的。菲尔不得不去找道具制作间的工程师们。还记得那个地方吗？对。他们设计并制造了它。兰迪说，还记得德怀特在白色圣诞节收到的核桃夹子礼物吗？
Oh, they're the same people? Yeah, this is very similar to where they basically said, create something that doesn't exist in real life. It has to work perfectly. And I need it tomorrow. And Randy sent us a test video when they were making it. It's really cool to watch. I'll put it in stories.
哦，是同一拨人？对，这非常类似，基本上就是他们提出要求：“创造一个现实生活中不存在的东西。它必须完美运作。我明天就要。”兰迪在他们制作时给我们发了一个测试视频。看那个过程真的太酷了。我会把它发到快拍里。
Here they are, Jenna, making this machine. It is incredible. It's really fun. I have to imagine it's exciting to get an order like this. Especially if you love to build things. Yeah. I mean, my dad would love to take on a challenge like this. My dad's an engineer.
这就是他们在制造这台机器的画面，珍娜。太不可思议了。真的很有趣。我能想象得到接到这样的订单会多么让人兴奋。特别是如果你热爱制造东西的话。我的意思是，我爸爸会很乐意接受这样的挑战。我爸爸是个工程师。
He would love it. Halston Warren shared with us that there were so many times they would write a joke into a script, not even knowing if it was possible. And then, lo and behold, this amazing machine would appear. And not only did this machine work to de-ply the paper, they fixed it so it would be a disaster when Dwight ordered Nate to re-ply it.
他会乐意之至的。霍尔顿·沃伦跟我们分享说，他们有很多次在剧本里写下一个笑话时，甚至都不知道这是否可行。然后，瞧啊，这台神奇的机器就出现了。而且这台机器不仅能把手纸分层，他们还特意把它修好，以便当德怀特命令内特把手纸重新合层时，能变成一场灾难。
It spins out like crazy. And they both shared with us that it truly made the scene that much funnier than they could have ever imagined. So they wanted to give Phil a big shout out. Yeah, it's pretty amazing. Before we move on from the scene though, Angela, I have one small little background catch
它疯狂地喷涌而出。他们两个都跟我们分享说，这确实让这个场景比他们想象的还要好笑得多。所以他们想对菲尔大加赞赏。是的，太神奇了。不过在我们离开这个场景之前，安吉拉，我有一个给喜欢这方面内容的观众准备的小小的背景彩蛋，在13分13秒处。
for people who like that stuff at 13 minutes and 13 seconds. What you got? The picture behind Dwight is still tilted. So I guess he knows that no one has come in to rob him because this picture is still crooked. And also, I noticed a plastic banana in his pencil cup. Don't know what that's about, but there it is. There you go.
你发现了什么？德怀特身后的那幅画还是歪的。所以我想他知道根本没人进来抢劫他，因为这幅画还是歪的。另外，我注意到他的笔筒里有一根塑料香蕉。不知道那是怎么回事，但它就在那儿。给你。
Well, Michael is being quizzed in preparation for his big SmackDown meeting with Oscar. Ryan says, where's Tibet? Michael says, pass. Ryan says, when was China founded? Michael, pass. Jim says, two for two. Keep it up.
好吧，迈克尔正在接受测试，为他与奥斯卡的巅峰对决会议做准备。瑞恩问：西藏在哪里？迈克尔说：过。瑞恩问：中国是什么时候建国的？迈克尔：过。吉姆说：答对两个。保持住。
Ryan says, who is Mao? Michael says, lifeline. And Andy goes, damn it, Michael. You're moments away from the SmackDown of your life. They encourage him to steer the conversation back to something he knows. Michael suggests boobs. But then he doesn't know anything about boobs.
瑞恩说：谁是毛？迈克尔说：求助热线。安迪说：该死，迈克尔。你离人生巅峰对决只有几分钟了。他们鼓励他把对话引回到他熟悉的话题上。迈克尔建议聊聊胸部。但他对胸部其实也一无所知。
No. And then Andy says, Michael, I have to tell you something. It's from Rocky, too. This moment is so funny. It's so funny. In the shooting draft, this is how it read. Andy delivers his rocky speech like Burgess Meredith, who was the coach.
没有。然后安迪说：迈克尔，我必须告诉你一件事。这是《洛奇2》里的台词。这个时刻太搞笑了。太搞笑了。在拍摄初稿中，它是这样写的。安迪模仿伯吉斯·梅雷迪思（也就是教练）的语气发表他的洛奇式演讲。
Ed kept cracking up Steve. Steve could not keep it together. And it made it into the bloopers. You have to hear it. This guy doesn't just want to win. He wants to bury you. He wants to humiliate you. And he wants to prove to the world.
埃德一直把史蒂夫逗笑场。史蒂夫根本控制不住自己。这被剪进了笑场花絮里。你们一定要听听。这家伙不仅想赢。他想埋葬你。他想羞辱你。他想向全世界证明。
How long is this going to take? I'll make a quarter of the way through. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. His face. I loved it when anyone could make Steve break.
这要拍多久？我才拍了四分之一。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。他的表情。我太喜欢任何人把史蒂夫逗笑场的时刻了。
Now Nate and Dwight are doing a little mom detective work. Frankly, they're going out to look for this building that Pam has supposedly found that's way better than Dwight's building. But guess what they drive up to? It's an empty lot. The building's underground. That's what Nate says.
现在内特和德怀特正在做一点妈妈侦探似的工作。坦白讲，他们要出去寻找帕姆号称已经找到的那个比德怀特的大楼好得多的建筑。但你猜他们开车到了什么地方？是一个空地。建筑在地下。内特是这么说的。
Dwight's like, you know what this means. And then Dwight's like, Pam. Pam, Pam, Pam. And then together they're like, Pam, Pam, Pam. And then a woman named Pam just happens to be walking by. Yes. We got a fan question from Amy Z and Westchester, Pennsylvania. How on earth did the extra Pam scene come together?
德怀特说，你知道这意味着什么。然后德怀特说，帕姆。帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。然后他们一起说，帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。紧接着一个叫帕姆的女人碰巧从旁边走过。是的。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州韦斯特切斯特的艾米·Z的粉丝提问：那个多出来的帕姆的场景到底是怎么拍出来的？
Who is this actress? From the whole series, I love the line, quote, I've been known to bend the truth. It's my absolute favorite. It is one of my favorite too, for so many reasons. First of all, if a perfect stranger says to you, you're not a liar too, are you? Her response was like, like proud.
这个女演员是谁？在整部剧里，我最喜欢那句台词：“我这人向来喜欢扭曲事实。”这是我的绝对最爱。这也是我的最爱之一，原因有很多。首先，如果一个完全陌生的人对你大喊：“你也不是个骗子吧？”她的反应就像是，带着自豪感。
I've been known to bend the truth. I know. Like where's this headed? I'm a little sassy. Well, Halstead shared with us that Charlie Grandy came up with the Pam, Pam, Pam joke. And he said they were trying to think of a funny out to that scene.
“我这人向来喜欢扭曲事实。”我知道。就像：这事要怎么发展？我还挺厚脸皮的。好吧，霍尔斯特德跟我们分享说，查理·格兰迪想出了“帕姆，帕姆，帕姆”这个笑话。他说他们当时在想那个场景该怎么搞笑地收尾。
And Charlie came up with the guys running into another woman named Pam, who was known to bend the truth. Halstead said it always made him laugh to think of this random encounter. The woman who played the extra Pam was Sarah Zimmerman. She is an accomplished theater actress and has appeared on The Closer, Big Love, and Desperate Housewives. And she is an Audi nominated audiobook narrator.
于是查理就想出了让几个小伙子偶遇另一个也叫帕姆、且向来喜欢扭曲事实的女性的桥段。霍尔斯特德说，每次想到这个随机的邂逅，他都会觉得很好笑。饰演那个路人帕姆的女演员是莎拉·齐默尔曼。她是一位优秀的戏剧演员，曾出演过《罪案终结》《大爱》和《绝望的主妇》。她还是一位获得过Audie奖的有声书旁白。
She has narrated over 300 audiobooks. Wow. Yeah. I thought she stole the scene. Stole the episode, really. It's so memorable. It really is. I had one background catch here.
她录制过300多本有声书。哇。是的。我觉得她偷走了这个场景。可以说是偷走了整集。太令人难忘。确实如此。我在这里发现了一个背景彩蛋。
If you notice, they're in Nate's blue pickup truck. Yes. It has an extended cab. And other than Sarah's brilliant performance, the other thing I kept thinking about was, how did our camera operator fit into that tiny backseat? It's not a full backseat. And at the end of the scene, Dwight looks over his shoulder.
如果你注意看，他们坐在内特的蓝色皮卡车里。是的。它有一个加长座舱。除了莎拉精彩的表演外，我一直在想的另一件事是：我们的摄影师是怎么塞进那个微小的后座里的？那可不是个完整的后座。而且在场景结束时，德怀特回头看了一眼。
So you know our camera operator was right there. Well, it was not just our camera operator. It was also director Charles McDougal. They were both wedged in that little space. Matt Sohn and Charles McDougal were in the backseat. And our sound guy, Ben Patrick, rigged up microphones that were hardwired into the vehicle. And they went to a sound recorder that was mounted
所以你知道我们的摄影师当时就在那儿。嗯，不只是我们的摄影师。还有导演查尔斯·麦克杜格尔。他们两个都被挤在那个狭小的空间里。马特·索恩和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔都在后座上。我们的录音师本·帕特里克安装了与车辆硬连接的麦克风。它们连到了一个固定在
in the back of the truck. Before we move on, lady, I have a fan catch from Alexander W. in Annapolis, Maryland. It's a good one. I looked and Alexander is right. After Dwight and Nate drive away from the fake office building, you can see a police officer on a motorcycle blocking off side streets of traffic.
卡车后部的录音机上。在我们继续之前，女士，我收到了来自马里兰州安纳ポ利斯的亚历山大·W的粉丝彩蛋。这是一个好彩蛋。我查过了，亚历山大是对的。在德怀特和内特开车离开那个假办公室大楼后，你可以看到一个骑摩托车的警察在封锁侧街的交通。
Oh, good catch. Yeah. That's what they would do when we would have to drive through an intersection. They would block the traffic for us. Back at the office, Dwight's onto Pam. He's going to start turning the wheels. Is that what they call it?
哦，好彩蛋。是的。每当我们必须穿过十字路口时，他们就会这么做。他们会为我们封锁交通。回到办公室，德怀特盯上了帕姆。他要开始转动轮子了。那是他们说的吗？
Squeezing the wheels? You twist the wheels. You twist the wheel? You twist the knob. No. What are we? What are you talking about? Turn the screws.
捏紧轮子？你转动轮子。你转动方向盘？你转动旋钮。不对。我们在干嘛？你在说什么？拧紧螺丝。
Sam, don't even. Sam is just looking at me shaking his head. What did you think it was? Turn the wheels on Pam? Turn the wheels? Squeeze the knobs. What is happening? I don't know.
山姆，别这样。山姆正看着我直摇头。你以为那是什么？对帕姆转动轮子？转动轮子？捏紧旋钮。这都什么跟什么？我不知道。
Anyway, tighten the screws. He's tightening the screws. And he's really questioning her about the specs of the space. What's the square footage? Where's the one sheet? She's a funny guy. She's a funny guy? That's what he says.
总之，拧紧螺丝。他在拧紧螺丝。他真的在盘问她关于空间的规格。平方英尺是多少？单页宣传单在哪里？她是个有趣的家伙。她是个有趣的家伙？他是这么说的。
He says, Pam, you're a funny guy. Oh, I missed that. Oh my God. It's such a great moment. Well, we had a couple of people write in with a fan catch that involves you, Angela. It's delicious. Nick N from Minnesota and Nicole W from Bowie, Maryland both
他说，帕姆，你是个有趣的家伙。哦，我漏掉了这个。哦天哪。这真是个绝佳的时刻。好吧，有几位观众写信给我们，带来了一个涉及你的粉丝彩蛋，安吉拉。太妙了。来自明尼苏达州的尼克·N和马里兰州鲍伊的妮可·W都
spotted that at 15 minutes and 51 seconds after Dwight tells Pam that he's the only one she hasn't asked about the new office building. And Pam replies, I know that's because you're the reason we're moving over my shoulder in the background as the camera zooms in on Pam, Angela can be seen quickly changing her computer screen and looking guiltily toward the camera as though she didn't realize they had started shooting.
发现，在15分51秒时，在德怀特告诉帕姆他是唯一一个没有向她打听新办公大楼的人之后，帕姆回答说：“我知道，那是因为你就是我们搬家的原因。”在镜头放大到帕姆身上的同时，在背景中可以看到安吉拉在她的肩膀后面飞快地切换电脑屏幕，并心虚地朝镜头看了一眼，仿佛她根本没意识到拍摄已经开始了。
And it's true. Oh, busted. Another thing would have happened right here. It would have been the second mention of Jim's rubber band ball in the early drafts it read act three interior office Dwight and Pam were at their deaths. Jim playing with his rubber band ball, which is now, and then in all caps, significantly larger.
千真万确。哦，抓包。这里本来还会发生另一件事。那将是早期初稿中对吉姆橡皮筋球的第二次提及：第三幕，内景：办公室。德怀特和帕姆在他们的座位上。吉姆在玩他的橡皮筋球，现在它——然后用全大写字母写着：显著变大了。
So I remember from my youth, these rubber band balls. But here's my question. Why did we have so many rubber bands that we could make a ball? What was being banded? I don't feel like I come across that many rubber bands now in my adult life. But do you remember?
我从年轻时就记得这种橡皮筋球。但我的问题是：我们怎么会有那么多橡皮筋，能做成一个球？什么东西被用橡皮筋扎过？我觉得在我的成年生活中，我不会经常碰到那么多橡皮筋。但你还记得吗？
Yes. People would make these. Yes. It was a way to store your rubber bands efficiently. But what was coming rubber banded? I don't know. The newspaper, I think is the only thing I have this rubber banded.
记得。人们会制作这个。是的。这是高效储存橡皮筋的一种方法。但到底是什么东西被缠了橡皮筋？我不知道。报纸，我想报纸是唯一一种我会用橡皮筋扎起来的东西。
But clearly Jim is bored, right? He's spending the day building a rubber band ball. And playing zombie soccer. We did establish that he had met his sales quota. Yeah, maybe this is a continuation of that boredom. I think so. We're going to have a little secret meetup of Jim and Pam in the stairwell.
但显然吉姆无聊透顶，对吧？他花了一整天时间在做一个橡皮筋球。还玩僵尸足球。我们确实确定过他已经达成了销售额。对，也许这是这种无聊状态的延续。我想是的。接下来是吉姆和帕姆在楼梯间的秘密约会。
Pam is freaking out. She confesses to Jim that she lied about the new building. It doesn't exist. Not even the bike path. Yes. Jim is also going to find out that Pam didn't use his camera.
帕姆快要崩溃了。她向吉姆坦白，她关于新大楼的事全是在撒谎。根本不存在。连自行车道也没有。是的。吉姆也将发现帕姆根本没有用他的相机。
I would have liked to have some reaction there. Oh yeah, that's true. Well, this is when she says she really, really needs to win this. Yeah. Because, you know, she failed art school. She failed sales. Jim says, what are you talking about?
我其实希望那里能有一些反应。哦对，没错。嗯，这就是她说她真的、真的很需要赢一次的时候。是的。因为，你知道，她艺术学校没毕业。销售也没做好。吉姆说，你在说什么呢？
You didn't fail. And I loved this line when they wrote it and I love delivering it. She says, well, I'm not an artist and I'm not a salesman. So what would you call it? And we get kind of a glimpse into maybe just some sadness that Pam carries around. And also how much this position that she created, by the
你才没有失败。我非常喜欢他们写出的这句台词，我也很喜欢把它念出来。她说，好吧，我既不是艺术家，也不是销售员。那你会怎么称呼它？我们得以窥见帕姆内心背负的一些伤痛。还有她自己创造的这个职位——顺便说一句，
way, really means to her. She needs a win. We had a fan question from Gabby C. in Huntsville, Alabama, who said, question for Jenna. In this episode, Pam talks about failing at things. I'm wondering, does Pam think she failed at being a receptionist too since she no longer has that job? I'm just curious what her thinking and motivation behind
对她来说到底意味着什么。她太需要一场胜利了。我们收到了来自阿拉巴马州亨茨维尔的加比·C的粉丝提问，她说：有个问题要问珍娜。在本集中，帕姆谈到了在某些事情上失败。我想知道，帕姆是否认为她当接待员也失败了，因为她已经不再做那个工作了？我只是好奇她那句台词背后的想法和动机是什么。
that line is. Well, Gabby, I did not feel like Pam felt she failed at being a receptionist, but I always thought that taking the job as a receptionist was something she felt she had to do. It wasn't maybe in her heart. She has that line early on where she says not many little girls, you know, dream of growing up and being a
好吧，加比，我不觉得帕姆觉得自己当接待员失败了，但我一直认为接受接待员的工作是她觉得她不得不做的事。那可能并不是她的真心所爱。她在早期有句台词说，没多少小女孩，你知道的，梦想着长大了去当一个
receptionist. You know, it's sort of like what you do when you become an adult and you have responsibilities, but it certainly wasn't her passion in life. But yeah, I think she's always carried around this feeling, just this longing to express herself in some way artistically. And, you know, she left art school because she didn't
接待员。你知道，这有点像当你长大成人并承担责任后不得不做的事，但这绝对不是她生命中的激情所在。不过，是的，我想她一直背负着这种感觉，一种以某种艺术方式表达自我的渴望。而且，你知道，她离开艺术学校是因为她不
want to get into graphic design. That wasn't how she wanted to express her artistry, but she certainly hasn't really spent a lot of effort figuring it out lately. And I think that's coming up for her. And I would remind myself of that as the show went on, that this was the thing that had gone unexpressed for her. Right.
想搞平面设计。那不是她想表达自己艺术才华的方式，但她确实也没有花太多精力去琢磨这事。我觉得这现在对她来说浮现出来了。随着剧集的推进，我会不断提醒自己，这就是她内心一直未能表达出来的事物。对。
We're going to head over to Caffeine Corner now. There would have been a third mention of the rubber band ball here. Well, it's much larger and he's banding the whole time that Michael and Oscar are debating China. And in an earlier draft, it would have said Jim, Andy, Kelly, Ryan and Aaron sit nearby around a small round table.
我们现在要去咖啡角了。这里本来会有对橡皮筋球的第三次提及。嗯，它大多了，而且当迈克尔和奥斯卡在辩论中国时，他一直在盘弄那个球。在早期的初稿中，上面写着：吉姆、安迪、凯利、瑞恩和艾琳坐在附近一张小圆桌旁。
Oscar turns to them and says, I didn't realize this place was so popular. Kelly and Ryan, mine being busy and in conversation. Aaron puts her hands to her ears pretending to groove to music. Andy pretends to eat a sandwich but doesn't take a bite. I want you to watch the whole scene. Ed hovers over that sandwich and never bites down.
奥斯卡转向他们说：“我没意识到这里这么受欢迎。”凯利和瑞恩假装很忙并在聊天。艾琳双手捂住耳朵，假装陶醉在音乐中。安迪假装在吃三明治但没有咬下去。我希望你们注意整个场景。埃德在那个三明治上方晃悠，却从头到尾没有咬一口。
And Jim is playing with his now bigger rubber band ball. Well, you know, at first it looks like Michael's doing pretty well. Yeah. He's got some good China facts. But ultimately, Oscar's going to start steam rolling him. At 18 minutes, five seconds, there is a great shot from Hank's point of view, looking at Michael and Oscar as they
而吉姆一直在玩他现在变得更大的橡皮筋球。嗯，你知道，起初看起来迈克尔表现得还挺不错的。是的。他掌握了一些关于中国的不错冷知识。但最终，奥斯卡开始对其实施碾压。在18分05秒时，有一个从汉克的视角拍摄的绝佳镜头，看着迈克尔和奥斯卡展开辩论。
chat. And I want you to know, you can see two boxes of the game Call of Duty under Hank's desk. Well, you have a good friend in Matt C from Virginia who is the same thing. Matt, did you see those? Yes. You know, you can also see paper bags and napkins.
聊天。我想让你知道，你在汉克的桌子底下可以看到两盒《使命召唤》游戏。嗯，来自弗吉尼亚州的马特·C也是个好朋友，他也是这样。马特，你看到那些了吗？看到了。你知道，你还能看到纸袋和餐巾纸。
I think for it to go items. I saw that. And the paper bags made sense. Napkins made sense. And then I'm like, what's the two boxes of Call of Duty? Also, if you look at the sign in the lobby behind Andy and Jim. Okay. You know, the little sign that says what all of the
我觉得是外带物品。我看到了。纸袋说得通。餐巾纸说得通。然后我在想，那两盒《使命召唤》是怎么回事？另外，如果你看一下安迪和吉姆身后大厅里的牌子。好吧，你知道那个小牌子，上面写着所有的
different offices are. The sign in the lobby now reads, the shrewt building under new management below Vance refrigeration. A lot of fun little background catches in this scene with Michael and Oscar. But ultimately Michael is going to prevail by giving a speech about how it's good to just keep talking. Yes.
不同的办公室。大厅里的牌子现在写着：文斯冷藏公司下属由新管理层接管的修特大楼。在迈克尔和奥斯卡的这场戏里有很多有趣的背景彩蛋。但最终迈克尔通过发表一篇关于继续交谈是件好事的演讲占了上风。是的。
And everyone's going to get really enthusiastic and riled up and they're going to love America at the end. Yes. Michael is going to do the thing he does. You guys were, he says crazy things with a lot of enthusiasm. He says, many people say you will get to China if you dig long and hard enough.
每个人都会变得非常热情和兴奋，最后他们会热爱美国。是的。迈克尔要做他常做的事。你们知道的，他说一些疯狂的话，带着极大的热情。他说，许多人说，如果你挖得够深、够久，你就会到达中国。
But what they don't tell you is that if you dig long and hard enough in a conversation, you get to a friend. Yeah. Everyone. Cheers. Case closed. Did you notice everyone leaves and goes up the stairs and not a single person gets in the elevator?
但他们没有告诉你的是，如果你在对话中挖得够深、够久，你就会找到一个朋友。是的。大家。干杯。案子结了。你有没有注意到每个人都离开并走楼梯上去，没有一个人坐电梯？
No, I did not. Elevators right there. No one uses it. Everyone's getting their steps in. I remember how excited we were to get those tables and chairs that remained there in the lobby after this episode because we finally had a place to sit down whenever we were shooting over in that area.
不，我没有。电梯就在那儿。没有人用它。每个人都在锻炼步数。我还记得当我们在这一集之后终于有了可以坐在那片区域工作的地方时，我们有多么兴奋能得到那些留在那里大厅里的桌椅。
Yeah. We'd actually hang out there. There was a deleted Oscar talking head that would have followed Michael's big speech. Oscar cannot believe what just happened. I thought we should hear it. Once I pay the coffee, that's the Kula Grah. It's over.
是的。我们实际上会在那里闲逛。有一个被删掉的奥斯卡单人访谈，本该接在迈克尔的长篇大论之后。奥斯卡简直不敢相信刚刚发生了什么。我觉得我们应该听听。只要我付了咖啡钱，这就结束了。
You can't make a 180 degree change of position. How can you possibly think you won? I don't know how to deal with tactics like that. Nice. But it also proves that Oscar knows exactly what he's doing when he invites you for a cup of coffee. Which is exactly what Jim and Andy said. We had a fun fan question from Tibi H in Belgium.
你不能来个180度大转弯改变立场。你怎么可能认为自己赢了？我不知道该怎么应对这种战术。太棒了。但也证明了奥斯卡邀请你喝杯咖啡时，他完全知道自己在做什么。这正是吉姆和安迪说的。我们收到了来自比利时蒂比·H的一个有趣的粉丝提问。
Was Oscar actually the smartest on set? I'll tell you who I think the smartest people on set were. Oh, I have my thoughts too. Oh, can we say them at the same time? OK. OK. Mindy and BJ. BJ, Mike, sure.
奥斯卡真的是片场最聪明的人吗？我来告诉你我认为片场最聪明的人是谁。哦，我也有我的想法。哦，我们能同时说出来吗？好吧。好吧。明迪和BJ。BJ，迈克，当然。
Paul. Yeah. Basically, our writers. Our writers were all so smart. But Mindy and BJ, I mean, I have shared, sometimes I would walk up to them just to be like, hey, what's going on? And they would be in such a thoughtful intellectual conversation that I would just slowly back away.
保罗。是的。基本上，我们的编剧。我们的编剧都太聪明了。但明迪和BJ，我的意思是，我曾分享过，有时我会走到他们身边只是想说，嘿，怎么了？而他们会进行如此深思熟虑的智力对话，以至于我只能慢慢地退开。
I don't know how to add in. I just like stand there and listen and stare at them and stuff. While all of this is going on in caffeine corner, Pam is going to get a little secret package from Nate. Yeah, he wasn't there. He wasn't there. And she's like, what? And he goes, it's a phrase.
我不知道怎么加入。我只是站在那里听着，盯着他们看之类的。就在咖啡角的这一切都在发生时，帕姆将从内特那里收到一个小秘密包裹。是的，他不在。他不在。然后她说，什么？他说，这是一个短语。
People use it. Feel free to use this phrase. Yeah, look into it because it could be helpful. Oh, my God. He's so funny. We had a fan catch from Abby S from Atlanta, Georgia, who noticed that at 17 minutes and 30 seconds, Nate sets the book down in front of Pam on the counter.
人们使用它。请随意使用这个短语。是的，研究一下，因为它可能会有帮助。哦，天哪。他太搞笑了。我们收到了来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的粉丝艾比·S的抓包，她注意到在17分30秒时，内特把书放在柜台前帕姆的面前。
But then just a few seconds later as Nate is walking away, suddenly the book is in Pam's hand and it's open. It seems like when did that happen? It's a good catch. Well, Pam is going to read something in this book. It's going to give her an edge and she's going to march right into Dwight's office. Yeah, she's going to say you're breaking the law.
但就在几秒钟后，当内特走开时，突然这本书就在帕姆手里而且是打开的。这似乎是什么时候发生的？这是一个很好的抓包。好吧，帕姆要在书里读到一些东西。这会给她带来优势，她会直接走进德 Dwight 的办公室。是的，她说你们在违背法律。
And she's got all the things that a landlord is supposed to provide in a workspace. And Dwight's not doing that. Yeah. And she's right. And he has to put everything back the way it was. She wins it. Yeah.
她列出了房东在工作空间应该提供的一切。而德 Dwight 没有做到这一点。是的。她是正确的。而且他必须把一切恢复原样。她赢了。是的。
The episode ends with them going outside and they're taking the big banner down and she's so proud of herself. There was a Dwight talking head that says, the best vampires don't bleed their victims dry, but give them the strength to bounce back and be fed on again. And he said he spared Pam, not because he was motivated by compassion, not at all. But he spared her.
这一集以他们走到外面摘下大banner结束，她为自己感到无比骄傲。有一个德 Dwight 的单人访谈说，最好的吸血鬼不会榨干受害者的血，而是给他们反弹并再次被吸血的力量。他说他放过帕姆，不是因为他出于同情，完全不是。而是他放过了她。
He let her win. Yeah. And during this talking head, there's a little bit of like a flashback of extra footage. We go back to that stairwell and the camera pans up and you see that Dwight has overheard this whole exchange between Jim and Pam. And he knows how badly Pam needs this win.
他让她赢了。是的。在这个单人访谈期间，有一些额外镜头的闪回。我们回到那个楼梯间，镜头向上摇，你看到德 Dwight 无意中听到了吉姆和帕姆之间的整个对话。他知道帕姆有多么渴望这场胜利。
Mm-hmm. There was a candy bag alt for this Dwight talking head and it read like this and I really liked it. B-roll spy shot. Dwight is in his car looking at Pam in the rear view mirror. She seems happy and Dwight's face betrays the slightest hint of human warmth. Over this spy shot, we hear a Dwight talking head.
嗯哼。这个德 Dwight 的单人访谈有一个糖果包备用版本，内容是这样的，我非常喜欢。B卷谍照。德 Dwight 在车里看着后视镜里的帕姆。她看起来很高兴，德 Dwight 的脸上流露出一丝人性的温暖。在这张谍照上，我们听到一个德 Dwight 的单人访谈。
Dwight says, she's clean. She's polite. She doesn't chat your ear off about medical dramas. Sometimes when Jim is being a tool, we'll roll our eyes at each other. In a way, she performs many of the functions of a friend. And then he goes on to say, so if someone had to beat me, I guess I'm glad it was her.
德 Dwight 说，她很干净。她很有礼貌。她不会跟你喋喋不休地聊医疗剧。有时当吉姆像个讨厌鬼时，我们会互相翻白眼。在某种程度上，她起到了朋友的很多作用。然后他接着说，所以如果非得有人打败我，我想我很高兴那是她。
Don't get me wrong. I'm really angry about that. Grr. I wish that had been the talking head. Wasn't that so sweet? It gave me chills. I know. Well, this episode ends with another win.
别误会我。我对那件事真的很生气。呃。我希望那是那个单人访谈。不是很甜吗？让我起鸡皮疙瘩。我知道。好吧，这一集以另一场胜利结束。
This time for Andy. He has texted Darryl. There's some crazy pigeon stuff happening in the parking lot. Yeah. There's two pigeons and they're eating an ice cream cone. And the script said they had ice cream all over their little faces. We had a fan question from Sarah C in Lubbock, Texas. How did the scene with the pigeons happen?
这次是安迪。他给达里尔发了短信。停车场发生了一些疯狂的鸽子事件。是的。有两只鸽子在吃冰淇淋筒。剧本上说它们的小脸上到处都是冰淇淋。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州拉伯克的粉丝萨拉·C的提问。有鸽子的那一幕是怎么拍的？
Are they trained pigeons and how much does a trained pigeon cost? Well, Sarah, Randy Cordray has an answer for you. We got those pigeons from Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals in Silmar, California. Denise Sanders was our head pigeon trainer. And it cost us $2,600 for two trainers and three pigeons, even though we only used two. How the heck do you train a pigeon?
它们是训练有素的鸽子吗，训练有素的鸽子要花多少钱？好吧，萨拉，兰迪·科德雷有答案给你。我们从加利福尼亚州西尔玛的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司弄来了那些鸽子。丹尼斯·桑德斯是我们的首席鸽子驯练员。我们花了两千六百美元雇了两个驯练员和三只鸽子，尽管我们只用了两只。到底怎么训练鸽子？
I don't know. But Bob Dunn, they know how to do it. They can train anything. So that made me laugh. I don't know why. Made me laugh. Well, that was China. Big thank you to Warren and Halstead for sharing with us
我不知道。但鲍勃·邓恩，他们知道怎么做。他们可以训练任何东西。所以这逗笑了我。我不知道为什么。逗笑了我。好吧，那就是中国。非常感谢沃恩和霍尔斯特德与我们分享
about writing this episode. Randy Cordray for all the great behind-the-scenes details. And thank you again for all your questions. Yeah. Next week, you guys, it's casual Christmas, and Holly is coming back. OMG, Holly Flacks. We'll see you then.
关于创作这一集的幕后故事。兰迪·科德雷提供所有精彩的幕后细节。再次感谢你们的所有提问。是的。下周，伙计们，是随意的圣诞节，霍莉要回来了。天哪，霍莉·弗拉克斯。到时见。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco.
再见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是里德·布拉特森的 Rubber Tree。如需 Office Ladies 的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 上免费试用一个月，请使用代码 Office。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。